All right, guys, I am now ready to say.
On the heels of the confirmation of Donald
Trump's nominee to the Supreme Court, Amy
CONI Barrett, that Joe Biden and Democrats,
if given the opportunity, must expand the
Supreme Court.
Of course, this depends on taking the White
House, taking the Senate, keeping control
of the House of Representatives.
I'm going to be calling it expanding the court
rather than packing the court.
When you say packing the court, you're already
ceding some ground to the right and making
it sound like something outrageous or radical
or aggressive when it's not.
I've made it very clear that on moral questions,
the left must not stoop down to where the
right is when it comes to dishonesty and authoritarianism
and the perversion of justice.
But when it comes to using the systems, we
have to legally fight against double standards
and hypocrisy and absurdity.
We actually have a responsibility to do it.
So let's go through and talk about it piece
by piece.
There are some on the right who say adding
justices to the Supreme Court would be a crazy,
unprecedented, authoritarian, undemocratic
thing for a hypothetical President Joe Biden
to do.
This is completely untrue.
John Adams reduced the size of the court from
six to five.
Thomas Jefferson went back from five to six
and subsequently up to seven under Andrew
Jackson.
The court went from seven to nine justices.
So the idea that it's not something that has
been done is wrong.
Now, there are some even on the left who oppose
expanding the Supreme Court because of the
slippery slope possibility that if Joe Biden
expands the court, the next Republican, faced
with a minority on their side on the court,
will then expand the court again.
And then the next Democratic spans the court
again and on and on and on.
First of all, this is silly at its face because
at a certain point, how big is the court going
to get?
Ninety seven justices, 131 justices.
It's not going to happen.
Okay, because the public wouldn't actually
stand for it.
And I'm going to get back to that momentarily.
But importantly, expanding the court is not
actually that easy.
If you have the same party controlling the
White House, the Senate and the House, which
we could have from 2021 to 2023, if Democrats
take the White House and the Senate, expanding
the court is not that different from passing
an appropriations bill.
But there are two reasons why it's unlikely
that we would go in this slippery slope direction
of indefinite expansion of the Supreme Court.
And the first is it's not actually that common
that the same party controls the White House,
the House and the Senate at a time when the
public would be okay with an expansion of
the court.
Barack Obama had the White House, House and
Senate for two out of his eight years.
And it's very common that at least one of
those three is controlled by an opposing party.
But maybe more importantly, there are many
political circumstances that don't lend themselves
to public approval of expanding the court.
And if the circumstances don't lend themselves
to expanding the court and a Republican or
Democratic controlled House, Senate and White
House decides to do it when the public isn't
in the mode that they believe it is appropriate,
they will be punished electorally if Donald
Trump is defeated and Democrats take the Senate
and we retain control of the House.
It will be one of those times where the public
will be okay with expanding the court because
the public knows the absurdity of the last
four years.
The public knows the ridiculous double standard
of Republicans saying no Merrick Garland during
the last year of Barack Obama's term.
But yes, Amy CONI Barrett, in the last week
of Donald Trump's term, the urgent need to
right that wrong, I believe, will give us
a population from 2021 to 2023.
That would be okay with an expansion of the
court if indeed Democrats take the Senate
and the White House.
So not only is there nothing unconstitutional
about expanding the court, not only is there
nothing unprecedented about expanding the
court, not only is there nothing set in stone
that one expansion will inevitably lead to
every future president expanding the court.
But if Joe Biden wins the White House and
Democrats take the Senate, we will have a
unique two year period during which the country
will understand that to get back on a more
correct path, we must take less common action.
And one of those actions is expanding the
court to get it back from these outrageous
lunatics that Donald Trump has put on the
court.
And for those saying that while it may not
be unconstitutional and it may not be undemocratic,
the reality is it is actually democratic.
Republicans have nominated.
Well, I'm sorry I said that wrong for those
saying it might not be unconstitutional, but
it is undemocratic.
Understand that Republicans have nominated
15 of the last 19 justices despite having
lost the popular vote in six of the last seven
presidential elections.
That doesn't sound democratic to me if you
disagree with me.
Let me know.
I want to hear
from you.